we are receiving reports uh hotly
anticipated before that the chancellor
quasi-cotting has been sacked let's
bring in immediately our Deputy
political editor Sam has he gone
two sources say that quasiquating has
been sacked as Chancellor this isn't an
official announcement they're not doing
that yet we will get that I suspect
fairly soon but two sources now saying
that quasiquating has lost his job
huge uncertainty about what happens next
because Liz truss appears to have just
sacked the man who was at her side all
the way through the leadership contest
has been at her siding cabinet for years
and who has been on the same ideological
Journey as her
for years for a decade and that means
she is now trying to save her
Premiership by drawing a line under the
last turbulent six weeks of her
Premiership and start afresh could it be
Jeremy Hunt who comes in to replace
quasi-quarting somebody very much not
seen as ideologically aligned to Liz
truss nevertheless uh potentially seen
by the party in the market as a more
safe Pair of Hands could it be somebody
else again no official confirmation two
sources saying quasi-quarting has been
sacked as Chancellor but the question is
is it enough quasi quateng is being
sacked it would appear
for uh implementing uh promises that Liz
truss you see in front of you and
sitting next to Therese coffee the
Deputy Prime Minister promises that Liz
truss made during the leadership contest
and it does appear as if that
essentially uh now Liz truss has tried
to save her Premiership by blaming her
we think recently ex-chancellor uh the
two of them looked like they were
getting on but there were other points
where you could see Stony faces from uh
quasi-quarting either at conference
which you just were looking at pictures
of uh or indeed out in Washington at
that IMF Summit the blue book that quasi
Crossing holding there is the book that
essentially writes the story of his
downfall it is the mini budget Maxi
budget really uh that he was heading uh
three weeks ago today to deliver in the
House of Commons
uh that uh essentially has rocked the
market undermine confidence of Tory MPS
destabilized Downing Street and has led
us to this extraordinary moment uh with
quasi-quarting looking like he's on the
way out two sources saying that he has
been uh sacked as Chancellor